nancy pelosi thought she was in for a
softball interview with 60 minutes
perhaps where she
thought she could bash president trump
uninterrupted but
things didn't go her way after pelosi
got called out for delaying coveted
relief for
months what about the covert relief
package
yeah that was held up for eight months
no
but that was their op obstruction i
understand this
wait was there obstruction yours their
obstruction
no yours too taking no it was an held
out for eight months
no we held it up because there was no
no respect for our heroes
and she was criticized by her own party
this guy i have his name here
dana preno bernie sanders he said we had
a much better deal
and i was stuck with 900 billion dollars
how do you live on that
i thought it was a great interview it's
one of the reasons ever since i was a
kid i was afraid on sunday nights
i didn't want to go outside and play in
the backyard on sundays because i was
afraid i would miss 60 minutes
so my dad would set the alarm on the
stove so that i could hear it
from outside and make it inside in time
to watch 60 minutes
um look she's got a she doesn't have a
good answer on that
because there isn't a good answer on it
but she did make a political calculation
she thinks that it worked for her
however the democrats now are in a weak
position
granted they just won the senate seats
um so they're in a much stronger
position that way but in the house
they're they're weaker
every republican incumbent won
re-election
um and plus the republicans need
something to rally around right now
the democrats seem intent on giving them
just what they need whether it be
nominees that they think are way too far
to the left or
ideas about increasing energy costs
raising taxes things like that
um she's going to have a tougher time
than she has had in the last few years
she does not like being challenged case
in point that right-wing zealot wolf
blitzer
had the audacity to ask her a tough
question listen
even members of your own caucus madam
speaker
want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars congressman rowe connor
i don't know why you're always an
apologist and many of your colleagues
apologize for the republican position
rolcana that's nice
that isn't what we're going to do and
nobody's waiting till february
i want this very much now because people
need help
now right hey dagon wolf blitzer again
caught being in that republican position
guilty she does not like being
challenged no she doesn't was that the
we feed them we feed them interview when
she said that to wolf blitzer was it him
it's hard to know i wish more uh more
people in the media including leslie
stahl in 60 minutes it called nancy
pelosi
out on her holding up this aid before
the election
that was her political calculation as
dana pointed out but they left one
trillion dollars thereabouts
on the table but again standing atop the
suffering of others
it's a good look nancy good luck juan
disappointed that she didn't do what
mitch mitch mcconnell did and
won against the president and said it's
time for us to come together she
all she knows is politics she has no
idea how to
come together on any type of compromise
don't you agree
well look i i think that you know i i've
just been watching a different story
than the rest of you because to my
mind nancy pelosi and president trump
both wanted a 2 000
stimulus check in the mailboxes they
both said this they said they wanted to
go big and it was the republicans in the
senate mitch mcconnell who would
not bring it to a vote i think that's
the fact i think that's what happened
i mean how do you say she doesn't
compromise when you got 600
the 600 bill because she compromised and
it was president trump
who was slow to even sign that but i
know you guys like to pick on nancy
pelosi
but i don't think their history is as
you've been telling it right uh
please don't put dana and dagin in the
same place as jesse
jesse how do you feel as compared to
juan
oh i mean i like watching nancy pelosi
get a little prickly there
you know she floundered at first and she
said oh no sorry leslie i didn't
obstruct
and then she goes oh actually i only
obstructed because our heroes were being
disrespected now
i have to give her credit as a spinster
myself
that is great spin our heroes have been
disrespected
the actual truth was she just wanted a
bailout fund
for liberal mayors and and governors who
couldn't balance their books and they
needed a little
slush fund to help them get reelected
and then later
she said oh yeah i obstructed because i
didn't want to
solidify injustice again
beautiful line and juan watch out
because every time the republicans
obstruct this new congress
i'm just going to say juan we can't
expect the republicans to want to
solidify injustice right and we'll see
what you said
absolutely i do wish on a serious note
that there would be somebody who thought
more about the country because we're in
a terrible spot right now
and will go out of their way to
compromise even if it means they don't
get reelected
i'm hoping someone will have the courage
to do that i'm not sure they're on the
roster